for panan with the pass all the way
across the laier and that shot by
and they put it in on the rebound Alex
laier crder panan Fox and Saban Jad for
the power play Fox with it and the
[Applause] shot long pass tick by
delene and the Rangers have
it paner shoots he scores
and now here's power up to center with 133
he crosses the line Power Shot is blocked
rebound [Applause] SC just ruled it accidental
here's theet shorthanded drives to the net he's
checked by Delan he got a turn up a score Jo
and I will have the play byplay at 7:00 on MSG
trouba clears it down the ice in the net blue
Jack is try to take advantage as they move in
but a nice sweep check by zamula and that sends
FY the other way two on0 with C F to C toy he
scores picked up by marchenko Full Speed Ahead
dises it out of the way save out the sck H rebound
SC and that was a problem there and the fers look
to take advantage of the turnover with a lton
moving up lton holds the pass connect the turns
SPS and he scor he'll play it this way high off
the glass and it gets past proov it's a race for
the puck and proov is not going to win that race
EMP It Go for cam ainson for him long shot blocked
in front of Hart Who incidentally picked up an
assist on Atkinson's empty net goal Maro into the
slot scores that will do it connecting moving up
two seconds one and he scores I believe it was
before the buzzer either way the Flyers have won
the hockey game game PA pinches back around for
Ras Muson spinning back toward the forehand out
in front vanich tried to poke it away and it goes
in a lot fought it free from Lin who is barking
at the referee as he heads off for a new stick
Jack H swooping in sharp angle [Music] [Applause]
SC chipped ahead for Hughes he's got Brad with
him Hughes to the slot he's [Music] here's CER on
net in the save B check Larin working the goal
line gets it out in front to break it scores
resurrected a square with Arizona Coyotes I'd say
very good for them in that power play quarterback
type role on the back end Hamilton midpoint scores
dug out of there by holla off to the wing for
marino marino finds Sean thaler SE ther off the
side of the net holl SC off to the wing try to
connect with Raymond gets it back from fab patries
out of the box toward the net traffic in front and
poto by Fab diving pass by Ben to get it off to
Johnston now delandria Ben the wrap around he shot
score trying to get through the weeds
at the line now Tucker shoots it right
on goal and a save there Tucker gets it again
shoots he stars out of the one hole is Jason
Robertson five for seven last year he's
usually the leadoff man in on Bennington
Robertson brilliant on the back end he makes
it look so easy mahura got their first Baldi
grabs a loose Puck at Center Baldi back pedals
down the wall back to the line faor a shot he
scores able to win the draw zuk carella back to
caprisa number seven zcell tried to go cross I
up front eron and score dork strant at his pass
stolen by Cole Smith right up the scene charging
after assistance he's got it he's carier to
Nyquist nist a no look pass he scor it backed
in is Fabro and then Fanning on the shot on the
other side was Yamamoto now to the empty Net score
so two kills for the golden knights six for six in
the young season on the PK for Vegas
Carlson drifting in curls the net Amo
scores on defense with the veteran Yan
Ruda here's a bouncing Puck to Zena he's
gone protecting it against baros works
his way back up the wall the trans alow
hag is open the one time scores a bom
from Nick K from the right side Ron in
the back check to move it around and Hutton
keeps it to neutral ice up ahead here's why
has a little bit of space walking out the
sces game over from Pittsburgh in the off
seon here's Bal out top his R sh score